-Everything all set?
Yeah. No, I'm --
I'm excited, too.
I hope I'm not jinxing it.
Oh, hey.
I don't ask a ton of you guys,
but I'd like to make
a quick request.
Can you all...
take the wax out of your ears
for a second?
It's a [bleep] Negroni.
Somebody said, uh,
"Houdini wasn't a magician,
he was an illusionist."
Magic isn't real.
Well, maybe you should give
that correction
to this dove.
[ Poof sound ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Scattered applause ]
"Everything's all set."
Find the dove.
It's got to be somewhere.
Bane, I was told Bane was never
imprisoned in Arkham Asylum.
If that was an effort to get me
to do my Bane, try harder.
I said Tele-mun-do,
it's Tele-moon-do.
Obviously,
I'm hesitant to say "moon"
lest I summon this guy.
This was sent in from a jackal.
A jackal made this.
I'm assuming in their basement
while their victims
were forced to watch.
I feel like if this guy
could talk, he'd say --
[ Imitating Bane ]
"As I terrorize Gotham...
I will feed its people hope
to poison their soul.
Hope and chicken McNuggets."
We said Trump's civil trial
could decimate his fortune.
A lot of you said "decimate"
means to reduce by 10%,
and of course, that makes sense.
"Deci" means "10."
"Mate" means "reduce."
I don't know,
I didn't do that part.
But I did look it up,
and there's truth to it.
So, in the military
of ancient Rome,
"decimation" was a form
of military discipline
in which every 10th man
in a group
was executed
by members of his cohort.
This discipline was used
to punish large groups
guilty of capital offenses
such as cowardice, mutiny,
and desertions.
I can imagine the hardest part,
is picking the one, you know?
Because, I mean,
we have ten writers.
I don't know how we could
ever...
Oh, Reiss.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of writers,
I showed this headshot
of Matt Goldich,
his new headshot.
I complimented how cool
he looked.
One of you said "Cool?
It looks like he went
to the barber and said,
'Give me the Richard Lewis.'"
People are obsessed
with the way I hold and operate
my pencil during "Corrections."
People think I tap it
too much on the desk.
Someone said, "Is your desk
covered with pencil marks?"
Of course not.
We switch out
the desk every week.
Which is probably why NBC
is always harping on us
about the budget.
Also, a lot of you thought
I almost poked my eye out
last "Corrections"
with the way I wildly
gesticulated with my pencil.
Let's take a look.
I also, we had a great --
I know what I'm doing.
I've been using a pencil
for a long time.
I've got nothing
to worry about.
Hey, there was a real
lack of lightness
to your comments this week.
This one was nice.
"Don't think it's there yet,
but Seth's Australian accent
was definitely better
this week."
Only problem?
Last week,
I did a Scottish accent.
Here's one that took me
awhile to unpack.
"Can we please get somebody
else? I hardly watch anymore."
Somebody else to do this?
You want somebody else
to do "Corrections"?
Someone wrote, "The amount
that Seth jokes about
how little his wife cares
for his career interests
or his feelings in general
makes me wonder
if it's actually a joke.
Are you guys okay?"
I mean, I think we're fine.
I mean, the way you said it
certainly didn't
make things sound great.
But, honey,
if you're watching --
No?
She told you?
Had a Rick Roll last week.
Got a lot of feedback
on the Rick Roll.
My favorite was
a back-and-forth --
because that's the great thing
about sometimes
you can really unfold
the jackal comments.
And I like when you
all talk to one another,
because it means you're not
talking to other people.
Someone wrote, "If
you're going to Rick Roll,
at least play the whole song."
Then someone wrote,
"The whole song?
That's not how
Rick Rolling works."
And someone said, "I don't care.
I like that song."
Well, to that person,
I just say,
you know how you're using
the internet
to watch this right now?
You can use it for other stuff.
It's not just for "Corrections."
Someone wrote,
"Rick Rolling in 2023?
Okay, boomer."
So now I'm a boomer?
I mean, I guess.
I do boomer things.
Like getting [bleep] trashed
with Dua Lipa
on a Friday afternoon?
Go to bed, kids.
The adults are talking.
But I saved the most --
the harshest for last.
"Rick Rolling and Meyers
are the same,
having been funny since 2010."
That's very hurtful.
But your words are not
going to change who I am.
No matter what you say to me,
I am never...
-♪ Gonna give you up ♪
♪ Never gonna let you down ♪
-The jack-in-the-box last week,
I found out it was made by
Beez McKeever,
who created props,
made props for
"Mystery Science Theater 3000,"
which is a fantastic show.
How about that?
That's just a cool fact.
Giant pandas and red pandas
aren't related.
This is a fact
the giant panda reminds
the red panda of every day.
It's where we got the expression
"red-headed step-panda."
Someone else wrote,
"The word panda"
originally meant the red panda,
but after the bear
was discovered,
it was named the Giant Panda,
and the original was called
the Lesser Panda."
Which was later changed
to the Fewer Panda.
This has been "Animal Flubs."
-♪ Animal Flubs ♪
♪ Animal Flubs ♪
-You're adopted...
bitch.
-Oh, no.
-Oh!
Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
And you're like, "Oh, you should
rehearse 'Corrections.'"
No.
[ Eyeball bouncing ]
You guys, pretty cool, this is
a true story, great thing,
my crew last week after
"Corrections" surprised me.
I went back to my dressing room,
walked out of my dressing room,
surprised me with
a 50th birthday party.
Totally caught me off-guard.
In my defense, it was a full
three weeks before my birthday.
It's a little bit like
somebody in February
going, "April Fools!
You should see your face."
You're like, alright.
They're like,
"Were you surprised?"
I'm like,
"Of [bleep] course I was."
But it genuinely
meant the world to me.
And it was the best.
It was the best.
Because, you know, one of
the things about any party
I have for my birthday,
I hardly have ever had any.
I have, uh --
my birthday is December 28th,
which is, I think,
affectionately known
as the holiday taint.
It's very rare for people
to get together,
so I appreciated that they
slid up the calendar and did it.
I got some presents.
Best present
was from Kenny Coyle.
Can't tell you what it is.
But I can tell you you spell
Coyle "NSFW."
I did get some some
Christmas gifts.
I'm a Steeler fan.
People know I'm a Steeler fan.
Christmas is coming up.
Someone sent this.
Very nice.
And then I would say that
is as nice as this is...
not.
"The Steelers
have won the toss...
and elected to kill."
-Oh, look at this.
Surprise present.
I guess the
birthday surprise continues.
-Look at that.
It's a one-winged dove.
Stevie Nicks week.